femme annie genevard merci l'ex-imam la
présidente la question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
notre agriculture souffre elle a exprimé
avec force ces derniers mois les
filières d'élevage en particulier
volatilité des cours renchérissement des
aliments difficultés des exportations
aggravée par l'embargo suisse l'embargo
russe prix de vente
insuffisamment rémunérateurs difficultés
dans le partage de la valeur ajoutée
bref les difficultés ne manquent pas
mais comme un malheur n'arrive jamais
seul voilà la fièvre catarrhale ovine
réputées contagieuses pour les ruminants
de larges zones de surveillance ont été
instaurées depuis quelques jours le
doubs terre d'élevage s'il en est avec
une race qui s'exporte très bien le
doubs est touché l'inquiétude est grande
monsieur le ministre si l'on ne prend
pas des mesures massives de vaccination
c'est toute la filière d'exportation
vers les pays européens et
extra-européens exigeants en matière de
vaccination qui s'en trouve compromise
la baisse des exportations a des
incidences importantes sur les revenus
des producteurs
dans ce cadre il est indispensable aussi
que les discussions avec les pays
importateurs comme la turquie l'algérie
la russie puisse s'accélérer afin de
trouver des solutions rapides et
pragmatique
j'ajoute qu'en cette période de comice
malheureusement annulé bien souvent à la
dernière minute
l'un possibilité d'exposer les bêtes et
vécu douloureusement par les éleveurs
monsieur le ministre
quelles mesures rapides comptez vous
prendre pour éradiquer cette épidémie et
soutenir nos agriculteurs merci la
parole est à monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture
madame la présidente madame la députée
vous avez évoqué un certain nombre de
sujets et vous avez d'ailleurs assez à
la fois précise et précisément et
honnêtement traduit la situation à la
fois sur les marchés sur la question
d'élevage
et sur l'élevage bovin et vous avez
rajouté cette question dfco vous avez
sur l'embargo évoqué bien sûr nous
l'avons tous compris l'embargo russe
s'est pas suisse mais sur la fc o
d'abord cette maladie a été détectée il
ya un mois et demi deux mois
à partir de là il ya deux stratégies qui
ont été définis avec les organisations
professionnelles et les services de
l'administration de mon ministère que
j'ai fait adopter
la première c'est d'assurer autant que
faire se peut la fluidité d'exportation
des bovins qui était déjà en capacité de
partir deux hypothèses s'offrait à ce
moment là je veux appelle un test pour
savoir si les bovins et et non pas
porteurs de la maladie mais sain et qui
ne puisse être exporté
ça a été négocié avec un certain nombre
de pays en particulier avec l'espagne
qui a accepté cette première procédure
et puis la deuxième procédure bien sûr
c'est la vaccination la fascination je
vous le dis sur ce type de fc o 8 pour
être précis j'avais trois millions de
doses de vaccins disponibles sur
l'ensemble du continent européen voire
nord américain nous avons acheté ces
trois millions de doses aujourd'hui plus
de 500 mille animaux ont été vaccinées
il faut qu'il y ait deux vaccins pour
pouvoir immuniser and animals et à trois
semaines d'intervalle
donc les premières vaccinations dépasse
aujourd'hui les 500 mille animaux
on va continuer pour les deuxièmes pour
assurer à partir de là et vers l'italie
et vers la pub gay
les exportations que souhaitent les
éleveurs merci monsieur le ministre la
parole d'un monsieur michel ménard